- Let's get to our first guests, y'all,
they are two incredibly funny guys.
I love both of these guys.
You know one from movies
like "The Hangover",
and the other from "Horrible Bosses",
as well as his recent blockbuster,
which my family personally loves,
the "Super Mario Bros."
movie, which was incredible.
Together, they star in "Fool's Paradise".
It's in theaters now.
Say hello to Ken Jeong and Charlie Day!
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
- Thank you.
Was that okay? I'll just sit down,
I'll sit down, I'll sit down.
- You sit there.
- I'm so excited.
- We're having a polite-off,
right now, a polite-off.
- A polite-off?
(Kelly laughs)
That's very Canadian of you, I feel like.
Canadians are always super polite.
- I'm Korean.
- I know but,
but it's a very Canadian thing.
I feel like they're always super polite.
Anyway, you just got
back from South Africa.
I love Africa.
- Yes, I had the best time.
- Did you do a safari?
- Yes, I did do a safari
with my wife and kids.
We went to Sabi Sands.
Shout out to Lion Sands Game Reserve.
First time ever.
Got to see the Big five.
- I've been to Sabi Sands!
- You've been to Sabi Sands?
- Yes!
- We'll be right back after
these messages, oh my God.
- It's so beautiful!
- It's so great. Got to see the big,
did you see the big five?
- It feels fake, yes!
- Yes. It feels, it does,
it's this immersive zoo.
- It's like "Cue, the lion."
- Right, I know.
And the lions knew me from "The Hangover".
It was amazing.
Like, "Can I get a selfie?"
I was like, no.
They're like:
(Ken roars)
(Kelly laughs)
I was like, okay.
- [Kelly] It is a really
cool experience, yeah.
- [Ken] It was incredible.
It was honestly the best family trip
I've ever had in my life.
- [Kelly] It's my favorite
trip I've ever taken
with family and friends, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So wait, Charlie, you're
from Rhode Island.
Which I feel like I've never said.
I don't know many people
from Rhode Island.
- Am I the only Rhode Islander
to get on this couch?
- But you say they keep you humble, right?
Like going back home?
- Yeah, I'm not allowed to be famous
and that's never ever gonna happen.
In fact, they'll roll
their eyes and be like,
"Oh, here comes Kevin Costner."
'Cause that's like, that's
where showbiz stopped.
At Costner, you know, yeah.
But it's good! It keeps
you, it keeps you humble.
I love it, I love it.
- I love people like that.
Still make you take out your trash.
Yeah, I like that.
My family does, too.
So, last time Charlie was here,
he talked about his
first time doing comedy.
So do you remember your
first time doing comedy?
- Yeah, it was an open mic.
I brought 20 friends.
Did well, performed the next week,
brought no friends and bombed.
So, I distinctly remember that.
And I stayed in medicine
for 10 more years.
So, true story.
- Oh my God.
It like broke you?
- It broke me, it broke me.
I did not do very well.
- It's so hard. I have
friends that do it too.
And it's so hard.
- [Ken] It's so hard.
Just live performance and to do that.
And you're just there with the mic.
Nothing else.
Yeah, when you do well, you
feel like a million bucks
and when you bomb, you're broke.
Emotionally.
- Yeah. Emotionally.
- And financially.
- Try doing that in Rhode Island.
Okay doctor boy, make me laugh.
- He's good, but he's No Kevin Costner.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my God.
- He's not Costner funny.
He's doctor funny.
Which isn't funny at all.
(Kelly and Charlie laugh)
- So what you're, I don't know.
So wait, your first really
big thing was "The Hangover"
and it's turning 15 next year.
Which is crazy.
- Wow.
(audience cheers)
Incredible.
- 15 years.
So I have to ask,
because I heard that you,
it was your idea to jump
out of the trunk naked.
- [Ken] Yeah.
- Is that true?
- It was.
I told Todd Phillips, the director.
Because I did have
slacks on in the script,
and I just said, wouldn't
it just be so shocking?
Because you had Mike
Tyson, you had the tiger,
that had already happened in the movie.
So I asked Todd, I said what do you think
about Mr. Chow jumping out naked?
He was like, "You don't
have to tell me twice."
And so literally he made
me sign a nudity write-up
that I couldn't change my mind to do it.
- [Kelly] Couldn't back out.
- Yeah, I couldn't back out.
- You said it! You said you would do it!
- You said it, you said it.
- I got it here, in contract.
- Costner would do it!
Yeah. I go, okay.
- Are you brave enough?
It was so, it was amazing though.
I just love that. That's a bold move.
- It was really just, honestly,
if it wasn't for "The Hangover,
I wouldn't be here between
either one of you right now.
I owe my career to "The Hangover".
- Honestly that, well you owe
your career to your talent,
but yes, "The Hangover"
is where we saw you.
But your talent is why.
- You're too kind.
- But are you one of those people?
Are you okay with it? I love being naked.
I'm okay with being naked.
Like a lot of people aren't.
Especially where I'm from in the South,
and they're very conservative.
I am not from there internally.
Like yeah, I'm a total hippie.
- I'm so shy.
- [Kelly] You are?
- Like in real life
where I don't even like
taking my shirt off
to go to the beach.
I'll wear like those tight skin,
like swim shirts when I go.
So for me, I think just
when the camera's on,
I'm just locked in.
- Is it 'cause you go into character mode?
- I think I go into character mode.
So, right now I'm like,
hi, how are you doing?
And then action!
(Ken laughs as Mr. Chow)
Stupid.
I don't know. It just,
it's a different thing.
- Okay. You just made me
feel weird in real life,
but it's totally fine.
- No, I'm not saying!
I'm not saying you're weird.
(audience laughs)
- I am, I just thought most people aren't.
I figured you had to be comfortable
if you'd do it on film, but nope.
- It's not insane.
- I don't wanna be naked
or in the trunk of a car.
(Ken laughs)
Neither.
- You would never do that in a movie?
- No, I'm shameless. I'd do it too.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
It's funny.
- [Ken] Maybe it's
something about comedy too.
You know, just taking
bold choices, big swings,
that kind of thing.
- And you know, I'm joking.
I don't know that I
would've wanted to do that.
That was gutsy, man. Well done.
- [Kelly] Made the movie.
So the new movie is
called "Fool's Paradise"
and you wrote it and directed it, too.
You did all the above.
So where did the idea come from?
- I started writing it almost 10 years ago
between seasons of "Sunny".
And I kept tinkering with it
and I shot it a couple
years ago with Ken here.
And then I sat in the editing room
and I watched Ken's
performance and I said:
Ken, you are the greatest thing
that I've ever pointed a camera towards.
Can I get you back,
and can I make this
entire movie about you?
And you said yes.
And I went back in and I retooled it
to be this sort of funny,
sort of almost bromance
between these two guys.
But it's loosely based on
Peter Sellers' "Being There"
which is my favorite film.
Ken plays a down on his luck publicist
who just wants to be a part of Hollywood.
And I play a man in a mental institution
who looks just like a method actor
who won't come out of his trailer.
And one thing leads to another,
and he sort of puts me
in front of the camera
and we go through a funny rise
and fall in show business.
But the movie is ultimately about
how these two guys connect to one another.
And I could not have
done it without this man.
- [Kelly] I love that.
I love that you were
inspired while doing it
and it almost changed it
and made it something else.
'Cause you're inspired by the
people you're working with.
That's bold to change something like that.
That's really cool.
- The movie was speaking
to me and telling me
it wanted to be as much Ken's
movie as it was my story.
And I said, okay, we have to change this.
And this man delivers a
performance in this film.
Like nothing, with his clothes on.
(Kelly laughs)
- But second to his nudity,
(Ken laughs)
he delivers emotional nudity and hilarity.
- Emotional nudity, nice.
- I think Ken gives a performance
unlike we've seen him
give before in this film.
And I really hope that,
you know, people see it
and that he gets the
recognition he deserves
for his hard work.
- That's so great.
(audience applauds)
I love that.
Well, this cast is insane.
Literally. Let's just name some of them
and you tell me what comes to mind.
So, I'm gonna start with John Malkovich.
Were you nervous directing John Malkovich?
- Yeah, there was a surreal moment
where I needed John just to
move a little to the left
because he wasn't quite
standing where the light hits.
And I was like, how do I
tell America's greatest actor
I want him to do something differently?
But in terms of his
ability to say the lines,
no, I left him alone.
(Ken laughs)
- I would imagine that
would've been tough.
So maybe just, oh, I don't know.
Maybe scoot a little to the right.
You're like nervous about saying it.
- Great, one more time,
John. And on your mark.
Just so the camera can see you.
- [Kelly] Just on your mark.
(Kelly and Charlie laugh)
- So you want me on my mark.
On my left or my right?
- That's pretty good.
- And scene.
- I worked on that for nine months, guys.
I need some flowers.
- Gimme my flowers now.
- Gimme my flowers.
(Kelly laughs)
- So Kate Beckinsale?
- [Charlie] Kate. Right, now.
I knew Kate was funny
because if you follow her
on social media, she's hilarious.
- Hysterical.
- But she, I hadn't seen her in comedies
or if she's been in
them, I've missed them.
So I was like, I would like the chance.
I had a lunch with her and
I said, I have this role
and it's a big role in the movie.
And it's very, very funny
but you have to do it very seriously.
And would you be willing to do this?
And the fact that she said yes,
the fact that this whole cast said yes,
was one of the most sort of
flattering, touching things.
Because I didn't know you
and I didn't know Kate,
and I'd only met John once and
worked with him for one day.
So, it was really--
- That's a nervous ask, just asking people
to be a part of this thing you believe in.
- Yeah, but I did believe in it.
And I believed in them.
They have a lot of talent.
- [Kelly] Yeah, we've heard of them.
They're gonna love it.
What was, I'm just
curious, speaking of music,
what was your first concert?
'Cause we've talked a
lot with music with you.
- [Charlie] Okay. Yeah.
So my first concert, and I
was trying to think of this.
I think it was Natalie Merchant.
- Whoa!
- And I think my friends and I--
- We have to be the same age.
I was gonna say, yeah.
- She was playing in
Newport, Rhode Island.
And I grew up in Middletown, Rhode Island.
My friends and I rode our bikes
and snuck into the concert
'cause it was outdoors
and saw our first concert.
I think I was pretty young.
- Yeah, wow.
What was your first concert?
- It was Prince, Purple Rain Tour, 1984.
(audience cheers)
- That's a good one.
- And I was only 23 now,
so I had a in utero
recollection of being in it.
(Charlie laughs)
- Your first concert
was Purple Rain?
- My first concert
was Purple Rain, yeah.
- That's a good start.
- It's all downhill.
- It all went downhill
from there.
- It was incredible.
I still remember.
- Oh my gosh.
- I still remember the White Dove.
He traded the Fender
for the White Dove guitar for Purple Rain.
It was just still in my
mind grooves right now.
- What a first concert.
- Yeah. It's incredible.
Incredible.
- Okay. Bragger.
- It was just the best.
I had great seats, wonderful popcorn.
- Prince looked me in the eye.
- Prince looked at me and
said you're gonna be a star!
I was like, thanks Prince!
(imitates eating popcorn)
- Also a doctor.
- And a doctor! Ow!
- I was like, thank you.
- You get all the talent.